I'm motivated by fear here of fear I
hate being scared to do something I hate
that feeling the feeling that I had
before I had a meeting with Quincy Jones
because it's really Quincy Jones and a
guy named Benny Medina and Jeff Pollan
came with the idea for the Fresh Prince
of bel-air and I hated being scared and
I didn't want to even take the meeting
there were opportunities during my first
year as a rapper Bill Cosby and the
people in The Cosby Show had seen my
music video and called me to come right
and try out for the Cosby Show and just
every time it was set up for some reason
I couldn't make it the fear I hated I
just hated that being scared to do
something and I think what developed in
my early days was the attitude that I
started attacking things that I was
scared I realized that to have the level
of success that I want to have it's
difficult to spread it out and do
multiple things in order to to be
world-class and I've made a decision I
want to be world-class it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus to excel on
the level that I want to make movies
when I was young I sat in a movie
theater and watch Star Wars and I just
couldn't believe that that movie made me
feel like that just floored and just
stunned by the creativity and I'm
realizing that in order to move people
in that way in order to touch people in
that way you've really got to focus with
all of your fiber and all your heart and
all your creativity you just watch -
amazing clips from Will Smith take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life belief
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]